so after about a month of preparation
and with about 3,000 unwrapped starburst
we are ready to steamroll our artwork
under that tarp the artwork I feel like
I just this is where I live now
still working on marriage at this point
so we've been unwrapping starburst for
the last six hours with the hope that
tomorrow
swish it with a steamroller and it turns
into beautiful artwork but who knows
[Music]
yeah
yes yes you guys feel weird that we
spent all week prepping for it I'm gonna
happen tomorrow too
you know what we're gonna survive
tomorrow regardless of whether this
works or not I think it's gonna work all
right so let's go to sleep and just see
what happens tomorrow what's happening
we are placing an D to be smushed
hopefully we'll have enough I think we
will all right I know that's the reason
I wore this shirt we are ready to
steamroll our artwork the artwork is
about 7 feet by 7 feet and it took a lot
of preparation and a lot of hard work
and we're finally ready to flatten it
and see what
oh my god
you can see it what you can see where
the Starbucks you can see the pattern
alright
oh yeah oh my god alright let's peel it
back this way
Oh
oh my god it smells like starboard
and we just smushed probably 2,000 of
our three thousand seven priests the
heart is the highlight but overall we
had fun and that's all that matters all
in all it was a success
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part